adam levine is here and adam if you
could just really quick put a number on
it
um the percentage chance that you will
play at gwen and blake's wedding
[Laughter]
adam levine's first post lockdown gig
could be wedding singer
at his former voice co-star's wedding so
the room 5 front man was on siriusxm's
the morning mash-up and said he's still
waiting for his invitation
to the much anticipated nuptials they
can't they can't afford me
yeah um they haven't asked me yet
yeah yeah i would love first of all
i was just texting with literally with
them
yeah uh i love them so much i just so
funny you mentioned them because i just
texted them
10 minutes ago just like i miss you guys
i love you guys um
yeah they're the best dude i i would
love to i'd be honored they won't ask me
they'll probably get like
luke bryan or something now back in
december blake claimed
he'd already shortlisted adam to play on
the big day
and in case you were wondering adam saw
that seth meyer's interview
i've kind of decided that uh
[Music]
you know i've been doing this a long
time now and i've got a lot of favors
out there and
and uh he may not like it but adam
levine's gonna have to
to get the band together and and come
and play our wedding
talking about marriage and he's like
yeah he's like i'm gonna get adam levine
to come play
he doesn't know it yet and i'm like
sitting there in bed like eating popcorn
and i'm like
man i'm not going to play your way so i
guess that's a no then
we'll see if blake's plan pans out now
this isn't the first mention
of a famous face possibly playing at
their wedding so miley cyrus back in
january tweeted that the pair
i'll be your wedding singer i promise to
be in my best behavior or worst whatever
you want
it's your special day cheers to loving
you both almost as much as you love each
other
so what did gwen think of miley's offer
well cheryl hickey found out back in
february
miley cyrus i heard that she offered to
sing at the wedding
would you ever take her she's so naughty
i don't really know about all of those
details of that
yeah who would sing at my wedding and i
don't really doubt
i i bet we couldn't afford miley cyrus
you know there'll be a lot of singing
regardless
now gwen still might not have an idea of
who she wants to sing
at her wedding but she does have a
pretty good idea of who she wants to be
standing beside her
at the author i know miley cyrus said
that she would
sing at your wedding is there anything i
can do
i was thinking about that a lot i was
picturing you in like a mob
like bridesmaid maybe made of honor you
know
we could put some extensions in and
we could do like make it like full like
flower arrangement
all that stuff you just tell me the time
and the place and i will be there